[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم قتل اكثر من 30 شخصا في تفجير
انتحاري استهدف احتفاليه نظمتها جماعه
الحوثيين في مدينه اب وسط اليمن نتوقف مع
هذا الخبر لنناقش
في محورنا الى اي مدى يمكن لليمن بدولته
وشعبه وقواه السياسيه ان يحتمل تفاقم
الازمه التي تتخبط فيها
البلاد وهل لا يزال هناك مجال للحوار وسط
استمرار العنف طريقه في التعامل بين
[موسيقى]
اطرافها كلما وسع الحوثيون من سيطرتهم في
ارجاء اليمن تتالت الهجمات التي تستهدفهم
في مناطق يختلف كثير من سكانها مع خلفيتهم
المذهبيه والقبليه معادله بادت تجسد جزءا
كبيرا من الازمه اليمنيه التي احكم العنف
قبضته على مساراتها في ظل غياب الهيبه
السياسيه والامنيه للدوله وفشل المحاولات
القليله الخجوله التي ارهنت على حوار بين
اطراف الصراع يعيد لليمنيين ما تيسر من
الامن واستقرار المعيشه
الى هذه الحال الداميه انتهت فعاليه
لجماعه الحوثي بقاعه المركز الثقافي في
مدينه اب اليمنيه اكثر من 20 قتيلا وقرابه
الخ مصابا وفق مصدر امني هم حصيله التفجير
الانتحاري الذي استهدف احتفالا للحوثيين
بمناسبه المولد النبوي في المدينه ذات
الغالبيه السنيه وكاله انباء نقلت عن وكيل
محافظه اب ان التفجير استهدف الصفوف
الخلفيه للقاعه ما قد يشير الى عدم نيه
الفاعل استهداف الشخصيات الرسميه التي
كانت في الصف الاول ومنهم محافظ اب الذي
نجى من الموت مصادر طبيه رجحت ارتفاع
حصيله ضحايا الحادث غير المسبوق في مدينه
اب رغم كونه الاحدث في سلسله اعمال عنف ضد
الحوثيين في اليمن منذ سيطروا على العاصمه
صنعاء وعلى مناطق واسعه من البلاد في
سبتمبر ايلول الماضي لم تعلن جهه
مسؤوليتها عن الحادث لكن الوضع المضطرب في
اليمن على نطاق واسع وخاصه منذ فرض
الحوثيون بالقوه واقعا جديدا يذكي العنف
في ظل انسداد افق السياسه يقول المراقبون
ان الحوثيين كثفوا في الفتره الاخيره
فعالياتهم لاحتفاليه بذكرى المولد النبوي
مستغلين المناسبه لتاكيد وجودهم الشعبي في
المناطق التي يبسطون السيطره عليها
ممارسات لا يستبعد ان تسبب ردود فعل غاضبه
من الاطراف الناقم اصلا على التغول الحوثي
الموازي لما تصفه تلك الاطراف بان بطاح
الدوله ومؤسساتها امام نفوذ جماعه انصار
الله قع لا تزيده الايام الا تفاقما ولا
تزيد معه فرص التسويات السياسيه الجاده
الا تلاشيه كذلك الحوار الذي انتهى الى
الفشل بين الحوثيين والتجمع اليمني
للاصلاح قبل ايام ليبقى اليمن مثقلا الى
حين بما لا تطيقه دوله او شعب من عوامل
الانفجار
الوشيك موضوع حلقتنا نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
الاستوديو مختار الرحبي الصحفي في الرئاسه
اليمنيه ومن صنعاء محمد البخيتي عضو
المكتب السياسي لجماعه انصار الله واحمد
الزرقه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكم
جميعا نبدا مع السيد الزرقه في محاوله
لفهم ما جرى واستيضاح الصوره يعني من
زاويه الجهه المنفذه لهذا التفجير وايضا
من حيث
التوقيت طبعا الى الان يعني العمليه واضح
انها كانت تستهدف تجمع الحوثيين و لعدد من
انصارهم في خلال الفعاليه العمليه تحمل
بالتاكيد بصمات تنظيم القاعده وليست هي
المره الاولى التي تبنا فيها تنظيم
القاعده مثل هذا النوع من العمليات رغم
انه الى الان لم يصدر الى الان اي بيان
لكن يبدو ان المزي ان العنف يجذب المزيد
من العنف ايضا ربما هناك صراع بين
الحوثييين وخصومهم السياسيين وتنظيم
القاعده على الناس وعلى يذهب ضحيته
الابرياء ا هناك ربما ما حدث هو يعكس ان
هناك حدث تماهي خلال الفتره الاخيره بين
تنظيم بين الحوثييين وبين الدوله الى حد
كبير تنظيم القاعده لا يريد مثل هذا النوع
من العلاقه بين الطرفين هو ايضا يبحث عن
خصوم او يبحث عن تحقيق انتصارات لما يراه
انه اهداف شرعيه ربما هذه وهذه هي ربما
جزء من سياسه استراتيجيه التوحش التي
ينتجها تنظيم القاعده في اليمن بشكل واضح
هو اصبح لا يميز بين الضحايا المدنيين
والضحايا من
انصار من انصار الله الحوثيين وبالتالي هو
جزء من سلسله صراع سياسي مغلف بطابع ديني
الجماعتان تتنافسان على نفس المربع لكن ما
حدث هو ان هناك الحوثيين يتماهون مع
مؤسسات الدوله والقاعده ربما هي ترى ان
التمه هذا يجعل جميع مؤسسات الدوله جميع
ايضا الفعاليات الرسميه التي تنظمها هذه
الجماعه اهدافا مشروعه لهم وهذا هو جزء من
استراتيجيه تنظيم القاعده ربما التي هي
ايضا
يعني فيها كثير من التوحش والوحشيه لكن هي
ايضا ربما الحوثيون كلما توسع كلما توسعوا
في المدن والمحافظه اليمنيه كلما ايضا
حاولوا استعراض وجودهم بشتى المسائي هناك
اطراف لا لا يعني يمثلها هذا التوسع
بمثابه تقديم الحوث سنع الى التفصيل سز
معلي سنعود الى التفصيلات لاحقا سيد
البخيتي الى اي مدى الحوثيون قادرون على
تحمل
مثل هذه العمليات والتفجيرات
الدمويه بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم في
البدايه اعزي اهالي الضحايا وكذلك اهنئ
الشهداء لانتقالهم من دار الفناء الى دار
الخلود يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى ولا تحسبن
الذين قتلوا في سبيل الله امواتا بل احياء
عند ربهم يرزقون فرحون بما اتاهم الله ما
اتاهم الله من فضله
طبعا اخي الفاضل هذه العمليه هي لن تؤثر
على اراده الشعب اليمني طبعا العمليه
واضحه ان هذه الجماعات التكفيريه تستهدف
ارهاب الشعب اليمني لمنعه من اقامه مثل
هذه الاحتفالات واحياء هذه الم المناسبات
ولكن الشعب اليمني معروف عنه انه شعب انه
شعب عنده قدره كبيره على التحدي والتحمل
ولا يرضخ لمثل هذا الابتزاز وبذلك ولذلك
فان هذه العمليه لن تؤدي الى تقليل اعداد
الذين سيحتفلون بالمولد النبوي في هذه
السنه في صنعاء وفي اب بالذات وانما سيؤدي
الى
زيادتها وبالنسبه لانصار الله يعرف الجميع
بعد استهدافهم مخيمات المعتصمين او
المعتصمين السلميين في التحرير ان هذه
العمليه لم تؤدي الى ارهابهم انا كنت في
التحرير يومها وكنت اشاهد يعني
عشرات الجثث ولكن مع ذلك كان ميدان
التحرير مزدحم الناس لم يفر
احد بل كانوا يتوافدون بشكل اكبر وبعد هذه
وبعد تلك الحادثه الاجراميه ما الذي حصل
تمكنت اللجان الشعبيه من من هزيمه تنظيم
القاعده في العديد من المحافظات في محافظه
الحديده في محافظه دمار في محافظه رداع
وفي يعني يقصد في محافظه البيضاء وكذلك في
محافظه اذا هذه العمليه اوغيرها لن تؤثر
على انصار الله ولكن سيد البخيتي هناك من
من يقول بانكم من خلال فرضك الامر الواقع
وتمدد عبر ارجاء اليمن هياتم المناخ
والارضيه لتفشي العنف يعني انتم تركزون
على البعد المذهبي في سلوككم وهذا ما
يقابله يعني ايضا سلوك مذهبي من زاويه
اخرى من قبل تنظيم
القاعده
ا اخي الفاضل لا يوجد في اليمن صراع مذهبي
وانما هو صراع سياسي فحتى الاصلاح او
الاخوان المسلمين لا يقولون ان هذا صراع
مذهبي لا احد يقول بذلك اضف الى ذلك ان
استهداف اليوم اليوم تم استهداف المجتمع
بغالبيته هو مجتمع سني مجتمع شافعي ولكن
كل اليمنيين حريصين على الاحتفال بهذه
المناسبه واستهداف الشعب اليمني في هذه
المناسبه هو استهداف لكل المذاهب انا اقول
لك انا اتوقع ان معظم الشهداء هم من السنه
وليسوا من الزيديه لان محافظه اب معروفه
انها غالبيه سكانها هم من السنه او من
الشوافع اذا اخي الفاضل هذه العمليه هي
تستهدف الشعب اليمني وتستهدف ارهاب الشعب
اليمني بكل مكوناته المذهبيه ولكن هذا لن
يؤثر وانما سيدفعهم ل يعني سيدفع عدد اكبر
الاحتفال والاحياء واحياء واحياء هذه
المناسبه طيب سيد الرحبي هل هل صحيح ما
ذكره السيد الخيتي من ان الصراع لان هو
صراع سياسي وليس صراع مذهبي لا تتداخل فيه
عناصر اخرى مذهبيه وقبليه وغير ذلك نعم
اولا نتقدم بخالص العزاء لاسر الشهداء
ونتمنى الشفاء العاجل لجميع الجرحى الذين
سقطوا بالحادث الارهابي الجبان الذي
استهدف التجمع في المركز الثقافي صباح
اليوم ولكن حقيقه الامر ان يعني ما يحصل
في اليمن كان الى الى فترات ليست بعيده
صراع سياسي ولكن ما يحصل الان هو اتجاه
نحو العنف الطائفي ونحو الصراع الطائفي
الذي يحاول بعض الاطراف السياسيه وبعض
الاطراف الموجوده في اليمن ان يقوم بحرف
هذا الصراع السياسي ليكون صراع مذهبي ما
حدث اليوم هو استهداف مذهبي لفعاليه
تبنتها جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين في اب
والجميع يعرف ان اب منذ عشرات السنين
تحتفل بمثل هذه الفعاليات ولا يوجد هناك
اي اي اي اي هجمات واي هجمات مرتده ولكن
نحن لا نبرر لتنظيم القاعده اولاي جهه ما
قامت بهذا العمل الارهابي الجبان ولكن
نقول ان يعني الخوض في مثل
هذه الاحتفالات او الزج بابناء مناطق لم
يكونوا يقوموا بهذه الاحتفالات سواء
بعاشوراء
او مقتل الامام زيد او بغيرها من
الاحتفالات اعتقد ان هذا يجر هذه
المحافظات السنيه والتي تحمل عمق سني
وشافعي الى مزيد من هذه العمليات
الانتحاريه ا
اي طيب اي دعني اتوجه الى السيد الزرقه
هناك واقعان يقال انهما يسيطران الان على
اليمن واقع افتراضي عنوانه العمليه
السياسيه يعني وكل ما ينطوي تحت هذه
العمليه ولكن هناك واقع فعلي يتمثل في
عناوين كثيره ليس اخرها التفجير الذي حصل
اليوم كيف نفم هذه الازدواجيه السيد
الزرقه
ربما الواقع الواضح الان هو ان الحوثيون
هم باتوا الطرف الاكثر تحكما بمسار
العمليه السياسيه في اليمن ايضا هم الطرف
الذي يعني اقصى المؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه
من مهامها واخذ على عاتقه مساله الامن
وايضا حمايه المؤسسات وايضا فرض القاط
امنيه في مختلف المحافظات التي سيطر عليها
وبالتالي يتحمل الحوثيون جزء كبير جدا من
العمل من الشلل الذي اصاب العمليه
السياسيه قص ان هو يعني كان هناك جزء من
صراعه كان مع جزء من شركاء التسويه
السياسيه السابقه سواء في في الاصلاح او
في اللقاء المشترك وغيرها وبالتالي ما
يحدث الان هو ان الحوثي تماهى مع الدوله
الى حد كبير اصبح جزء من من المؤسسه
العسكريه اصبح جزء حتى القرارات التي تصدر
اصبح لابد ان يوافق عليها الحوثيون بشكل
واضح لابد ان يكون لهم محاصصه في جميع
الوزارات وبشكل ربما اكثر او يفوق حجم
الحوثيين على على الارض بالنسبه لعدد
السكان او بالنسبه
للمساحه لكونهم حركه دينيه وليسوا حركه
سياسيه الى الان ما زال الحوثيون حركه
دينيه هم يقولون انهم حركه قائمه يسموا
انفسهم المسيره القرانيه وبالتالي الى
الان لم يتحولوا الى حركه سياسيه هم حركه
دينيه تستقوي بالسلاح وتفرض هيمنتها وجندت
على المؤسسات الدوله اليمنيه وعلى الدوله
وبالتالي لا يمكن الحديث عن اي دور لاي
قوى اخرى خارج حسابات الحوثيين ما دام
الحوثيين هم من يستولوا على مقاليد السلطه
في البلاد وهم ايضا من يقوموا ايضا ايض
بفرض الامر الواقع سواء على الرئيس هادي
او على بقيه المؤسسات حتى في قضيه
التعيينات عندما يعترضوا على وزير او على
مسؤول يتم منعه من دخول هذه المؤسسه او
تلك بحجه يعني محاربه الفساد و يعني
والاستمرار في عمليه التغيير حتى حتى الان
ما زال الحوثيون حركه هلاميه غير واضحه
الملامح هي تحاول ان تدير الاوضاع من خلف
الكواليس لكنها الان هي من هي من اصبحت
واضحه المعالم في المشهد السياسي اليمني
واصبحت ايضا يعني تستفرد بصنع القرار
وتستفرد خاصه بالقرارين السياسي والامني
وبالتالي ما يحدث اليوم هو عباره اعلان
صريح لفشل الحوثيين في الاستمرار وحيدين
في الساحه السياسيه اليمنيه
وايضا فشل ل سياسه الاقصاء التي يقوموا
بها ضد بقيه الاطراف السياسيه سيد البخيتي
يعني السؤال المليون دولار مازال مطروحا
الى حد الان في اليمن يعني اخر من من طرحه
مستشار الرئيس اليمني السلطان حزام
العتواني يقول لم نفهم ماذا يريد الحوثيون
ماذا
تريدون اخي الفاضل الامر
واضح نحن نريد القضاء على الفساد في كل
مؤسسات الدوله بشكل كامل نحن نريد ان نرفع
الظلم عن هذا الشعب اليمني وان تعود
الحقوق المغتصبه والمنه الى
المواطنين نحن نريد ايضا توفير الامن لهذا
البلد ولهذا الوطن للاسف الشديد ان
الحكومه ان النظام السابق والنظام اللاحق
بعد ثوره
2011 لم يستطع ان يوفر هذه المطالب الفساد
لا يزال م مستمرا الظلم لا يزال مستمرا
وكذلك الخلل الامني لا يزال مستمرا ونحن
الان قد حققنا الكثير من الانجازات في
مجال مكافحه الفساد حيث وفرنا حتى الان
مليارات الريالات لخزينه الدوله اضف الى
ذلك رفعنا الكثير من المظلوميات عن كاهل
المواطنين ووفرنا الامن للمواطنين في
الكثير من المحافظات على سبيل المثال كانت
مثل محافظه الجوف ومحافظه عمران ومحافظه
صعده يقتل فيها المئات في كل شهر اما الان
فقد يعني توقفت هذه الثارات اذا نحن نسعى
لتحقيق هذه المطالب لهذا الشعب وهذا واجب
علينا وحق لهذا الشعب سيد الرحبي السؤال
ايضا اين الدوله اليمنيه في كل هذا مع
تفاقم هذه الازمه اين الرئيس علي عبد ربو
منصور هادي اين حكومه الوفاق لماذا لم
ينجح الى حد الان في تدارك هذه
الهشاشه التي توصف بها الدوله اليمنيه الى
حد الان للاسف الشديد انه كلما تم توقيع
اتفاقيات بين جميع الاطراف السياسيه في
اليمن منها اتفاق المبادره الخليجيه
واليتها التنفيذيه ايضا الدخل في حوار
الوطني اخر هذه الاتفاقيات هي اتفاقيات
السل المشتركه ولكن لكن للاسف الشديد انه
لا يتم تنفيذ هذه الاتفاقيات يعني اخر
اتفاقيه كانت هي اتفاقيه السلم والشركه
يعني قبلها بساعات كان الحوثيين يغزون
العاصمه صنعاء ويغزون المحافظات وتم اسقاط
الدوله وتم السيطره على مؤسسه الدوله
والوزارات هناك طرف سياسي يحاول سواء من
الحوثيين او الارتباط بالنظام السابق
يحاولون اضعاف الدوله ويحاولون ان تكون
الدوله هشه لكي يتسنى لهم الانقضاض على
الدوله والسيطره عليها بجميع مفاصلها سواء
السياسيه او في الجانب السياسي او في
الجانب على ارض الواقع وما هو موجود حاليا
هو يعني تمكين لهذه المليشيات المسلحه من
القيام بواجب الدوله واضعاف الدوله
المركزي للدوله سيد الزرقه مع كل ما ما
يجري هل تعتقد ان هناك مازال باب امل
للحوار بالرغم من فشل بعض جولته
السابقه ا ربما هو ليس ليس هناك مخرج غير
الحوار لكن الحوار هذا بحاجه الى اولا
تسويه الارضيه الملعب السياسي ارضيه
الملعب السياسي في اليمن لابد اولا من
وجود شكل واضح للدوله لابد ايضا من ربما
تغيير وجوه او مرا يعني المرحله
الانتقاليه الحاليه لابد ايضا من ان
الرئيس هادي ان ان ان يعني يخرج من سباته
الطويل او ربما ايضا يجب الاطراف السياسيه
الاخرى ان تسكل صفا واضحا في موازه
الحوثيين وايضا الوقوف في وجهه خاصه ان
الحوثي الى الان لم يجد اي طرف سياسي
يقاومه وبالتالي هو يستمر هو ليس بحاجه
للحوار نظرا لعدم وجود معارضه سياسيه او
معارضه في الشارع اليمني بشكل كبير جدا
وبالتالي لا يوجد ما يجبره على الالتزام
باي اتفاقيات نظرا لان جميع
الاطراف او النخب
السياسيه اليمنيه تبحث عن الخلاص الفردي
وعن تسويات لمصالحها بشكل فردي مع الحوثي
وهذا ما حدث مع عدد من قيادات الحزبيه
والقيادات السياسيه في البلاد وبالتالي ا
يعني الحوثي هو لا يوجد ما يخسر بالعكس هو
يكسب يوميا يكسب ماديا يكسب عسكريا لكنه
يخسر الكثير في مقابل ذلك سياسيا يخسر
سمعته يخسر ايضا من الاخطاء التي يقوم بها
الميليشيات التي التابعه له ما زال يعني
هناك حديث عن الفساد وعن يعني تصحيح وما
زالت يعني اموال الدوله تنهب من قبل
ميليشيات الحوثيين ما زال الحوثيين يفرضون
اتاوات على المؤسسات الدوله ما زالوا ايضا
يقتحمون المؤسسات والمعسكرات وما زالت
اسلحه الدوله في حوزته في صعده وفي غيرها
من المناطق وبالتالي الحوثي هو يعني هي
ميليشيات اصبحت تتغول على الدوله وبالتالي
هو مستفيد من جمع من ضعف الدوله وم ضعف
بقيه الاطراف السياسيه لا يوجد
حل يعني سواء اجبار الحوثي على الحوار ان
عندما تتواجد الفعاليات السياسيه بشكل
واضح في الميدان وعندما ت يكون لديها
مشروع وطني جامع لكن فيها الحال الراهن
هناك بحث عن تسويات فرديه عن ربما اتفاقات
سريه تحت الطاوله لكن الى الان لا بد ان
يكون هناك حاجه يعني ان يدرك اليمين ان
هناك حاجه الى استعاده الدوله لابد من
انهاء الدستور وايضا لابد من انهاء
المرحله الانتقاليه التي طالت طال امدها
من سنتين نكاد ندخل العام الخامس سيد
الخيتي سيد البخيتي اي الخيارات الان
مطروحه امامكم هل التصعيد العسكري مقابل
التصعيد ام الركون الى الحل السياسي ولكن
يبدو ان اخر جوله من من المفاوضات من
الحوار مع ال يعني جبهه الاصلاح او حزب
الاصلاح فشلت هل هذا عنوان فرعي
لربما مسار كامل من من الحوار في
المستقبل خيارنا هو تنفيذ اتفاق السلم
والشراكه الوطنيه وكذلك تنفيذ مخرجات
الحوار الوطني هذا هو خيارنا والاخ يقول
اننا يعني نضعف الدوله ما يضعف الدوله هو
[__] اسمرار الفساد واستمرار الظلم انا
اتساءل لماذا كان هناك فرصه امام الرئيس
هادي بان يختار وزراء يعني لا ليس عليهم
اي ملفات فساد لماذا لم يحرص الرئيس هادي
على اختيار وزراء نزيهين لماذا لا يحرص
الرئيس هادي على تغيير كل رموز الفساد في
مؤسسات الدوله واستبدالهم بناس نزيهين ومن
ذوي الكفاءه ما الذي يمنعه ذلك نحن الشعب
اليمني يعرف من الفاسد يعرف من صاحب كفاءه
هل يعقل ان الرئيس هادي بكل هذه الاجهزه
الرقابيه لا يعرف هذا الشيء اذا اخي
الفاضل ما يضعف الدوله هو بقاء الفاسدين
وهؤلاء الفاسدين هم يستشعرون ان وجود
انصار الله سواء كقوه شعبيه وايضا كقوه
داخل مؤسسات الدوله سيؤثر على مصالحهم
لذلك هناك تحالف بين هؤلاء الفاسدين وكذلك
للاسف الشديد وبين الرئيس دي لان الرئيس
هادي يعرف انه اذا احال الكثير من
الفاسدين حتى من المحسوبين على علي عبد
الله صالح فانه لا بد ان يوقف فساده لابد
ان يوقف فساد ابنه جلال هادي اذا اخي
الفاضل ها يعني لا زالت الامور تدار بارث
المرحله السابقه اذا كانت هذه السلطه
الرئيس هادي ورئيس الوزراء والوزراء
يريدون استعاده المبادره فعليهم ان
يتحركوا بشكل نزيه ويكافح الفساد بشكل
نزيه في مؤسسات الدوله تحيل اخي الفاضل
انا ساضرب مثال على سبيل المثال باختصار
ساضرب مثال في الفساد هذا مثال حتى في
الشعب اليمني مثلا عن نحن عندما نشتري
المشتقات النفطيه من الخارج لا لا تشتريها
الحكومه بشكل مباشر وانما عبر وسطاء هذا
يكلف الدوله 25 مليون دولار شهريا اي 300
مليون دولار شهريا نحن قلنا لهم يجب ان
تتوقف يجب ان تشتري الدوله بشكل مباشر
قالوا لا ورفضوا هذا الشيء بعد ذلك قامت
اللجان الشعبيه بالتواصل مع بعض الموردين
وقالوا نعم سيوفرون النفط بهذه الاسعار
المشتقات النفطيه يوفرها والان باعتراف
الشركه النفط وباعتراف وسائل الاعلام
التابعه للسلطه انه تم توفير 25 مليون
دولار شهريا بشراء النفط بشكل مباشر هذا
تم بضغط قوي من اللجان الشعبيه طيب طيب سي
سيد الرحبي يعني يقول سيد البخيتي ان
الدوله مازالت تدار بعقليه وبارث المرحله
السابقه هل الدوله الان اي
تصور يعني واضح للمرحله المقبله لاخراج
البلاد من هذه الازمه امالها ت تكتفي فقط
باداره الازمه بالعكس الدوله من المؤكد ان
لديها خطط ولديها استراتيجيات لكن للاسف
الشديد ان هناك معوقات تقف امام هذه
الاستراتيجي وامام الخروج من الوضع
الماساوي للبلد الاخ محمد يتحدث عن الفساد
ويتحدث عن اتفاق السلم والشراكه ومخرجات
الحوار الوطني وهو لا يدري ان اتفاق السلم
والشراكه ينص على انه بعد اداء حكومه
الكفاءات الوطنيه اليمين الدستوري على على
المليشيات المسلحه التابعه للحوثيين
الانسحاب من العاصمه صنعاء وتسليم السلاح
للدوله ولكن هذا لم يحصل ما حصل هو تمدد
للحوثيين لخارج العاصمه صنعاء دخلوا
محافظات كثيره خاضوا حروب بالوكاله فهذا
يضعف الدوله ويضعف مؤسسات الدوله واي حديث
عن الفساد وعن مكافحه الفساد ياتي عبر
اطار مؤسسي وعبر مؤسسات الدوله وليس عبر
اللجان لجان ثوريه ياتي ابو احمد او ابو
اسماء لا نعرفها ويقوم بالدخول واقتحام
مؤسسات الدوله وشركه صافر ومؤسسات كثيره
من الدوله ويقول انه يكافح الفساد نحن
جميعا مع مكافحه الفساد نحن جميعا ضد
الفاسدين ونسعى جميعا الى ان تكون اليمن
خاليه من الفساد ولكن تحت عناوين معروفه
وتحت اطار مؤسسات شرعيه ومؤسسات الدوله هو
ينتقل الان من مؤسسه الشرعيه الى مؤسسه
ثوريه ويعطي الشرعيه الى الميليشيات والى
الجماعات المسلحه لتقوم بمكافحه الفساد في
اطار انتقاء وليس باطار عام هناك فاسدين
لا يتم الالتفات لهم هناك فاسدين لا يقول
عنهم هؤلاء فاسدين ولكن من طرف سياسي معين
ومن اطراف معينه يتم استهدافهم عبر هذه
اللجان الثوريه سيدي الزرقه بناء على ما
يقال بان اليمن هو بالنهايه يعني صندوق
بريد يقع تبادل الرسائل على ارضه هل الدور
الاقليمي والدور الدولي هنا دور فاعل معزز
للحوار الوطني الداخلي ام ربما مفش له
ومعرق
له اليمن يعني تحتل اهميه فقط ربما في
الادبيات في بيانات المنظمات الدوليه في
بيانات ايضا الدول الاقليميه كل جميع
اتحدث عن مخاطر وخطوره الوضع في اليمن لكن
يبدو انها جميعها تسعى لخلق بؤر يعني توتر
غير مستقره وايضا ربما لتبادل ال
يعني المشاكل والصعوبات في هذه المنطقه من
البلد من من العالم لكن لا يحضى اليمن
بالاهميه الاستراتيجيه في في اولويات دول
المنطقه سواء دول الخليج او حتى امريكا او
حتى ربما الطرف الفاعل حاليا في الفتره
الاخيره هو ايران التي ربما لديها
استراتيجيه واضحه استطاعت خلال سنوات
قليله ان تصل بها الى مصاف متقدم وتجاوزت
به حتى الدور الاقليمي بقيه الدول في
المنطقه التي لديها كان لديها عمق علاقات
مع المراكز القوى في اليمن لكن يبدو الى
الان ان اليمن ستكون ستظل ورقه بيد
الاطراف الدوليه تصارع
بها وهي تريدها في حاله حاله من الموت
السريري الدائم كي لا تسبب ربما مشاكل او
تخرج عن السيطره ما يحدث الان ربما هو
يعني شغل الاطراف اليمنيه داخل اليمن
بالصراع طويل المدى بحيث انها تتفرغ
للمشاكل الداخليه ولا تستطيع تجاوز يعني
او الانتقال بالتاثير على الى دول الجوار
الدور الايراني اصبح واضح بشكل كبير جدا
هناك تراجع سعودي هناك تراجع خليجي هناك
ايضا تراجع امريكي ايضا المبادره الخليجيه
تراجعت الى الخلف بشكل كبير جدا الدول
العشر ربما انسحبت الى حد كبير وجميع
الاطراف تراقب ما الذي يستطيع ان يقوم بها
الحوثي خلال الفتره الماضيه شكرا جزيلا لك
احمد الزرقه الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اشكر
السيد محمد البخيتي عضو المكتب السياسي
لجامعه انصار الله وضيفنا في الاستوديو
السيد مختار الرحبي الصحفي في الرئاسه
اليمنيه بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من برنامج
مورا الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في جديده في
ما وراء خبر جديد دمتم
[موسيقى]
بخير